this
[Music]
[Applause]
is bring in Bob Kravitz the senior staff
writer for the athletic who's based in
Indianapolis former indie star columnist
how did this go over yesterday locally
like a lead balloon yeah not good
um I bought Jeff Saturday uh comported
himself great I mean he was erudite he
was enthusiastic
um he was everything you'd want
um you know from a guy being introduced
to this press conference I thought Chris
Ballard looked like he'd rather be
vacationing in Tehran he did not look
happy to be there at all I mean I'm not
a body language expert but um arms
crossed and jaw set he did not look
happy and Jim was just incoherent
um he rambled he was incoherent uh he
was Defensive it was uh it was a bad
look for this organization that has had
a lot of bad looks in recent years okay
how did we get to this point
well uh you know the the thing that was
strange to me was they felt that this
was falling apart and they needed to
make a move from Frank Reich but ersei
made it clear that Jeff Saturday wasn't
available this never would have happened
which I have a hard time believing uh
they had soured on Frank
um you look Frank was 40 33-1 with five
quarterbacks in five years it doesn't
excuse the impotent uh offense we saw
against New England last week no it does
not but
um it was a it was a move they felt they
needed to make
um I have a hard time believing that
Saturday was the only option for them to
to move forward
but you start to look at this and we had
orlovsky on and he said you know you
bring Saturday in but they really want
to get a great draft pick so they can
get their quarterback here you're you're
bringing him in but you don't want him
to be that good because if he's that
good now you put him in no man's land
and you're drafting 11th
well we're all screwed up here in
Indiana the Pacers are supposed to be
the ones
okay they're the ones that supposed
and therefore four and five and look
Turtles were supposed to uh you know be
competitive for the AFC South and
they're tanking yes I I think in a
completely screwy back backhanded sort
of way they want to lose they need to
tank so they can get a top five top
seven pick and go get Bryce young or CJ
Stroud or Hendon hooker or whoever it
might be so this may work out in the end
somehow
but you don't have an offensive play
caller on the staff no no and what's
Saturday's job going to be coming up
this weekend
well uh first you know I Orlowski had a
good point he uh the other day he said
why don't they let Matt Ryan call the
police yeah I agree and everybody
laughed and I thought that makes as much
sense as anybody else well you are
paying him like you are paying him a lot
of money 18 million dollars or something
so you know put them to work for crying
out loud you can't tell me he doesn't
know the offense any better than in any
of these assistants so uh Saturday said
yesterday that he was going to make a
decision last night on who the play
caller was going to be he's already
confirmed that Sam Ellinger Heaven help
him will be the starter against Vegas uh
Bernard Raymond will be the left tackle
and I just expect more of the same I I
you know I look you we root around here
for for guys like Saturday but he's an
impossible in an impossible position Dan
Bob Kravitz senior staff writer for the
athletic based in Indianapolis covering
Nicole's uh I'm gonna try to ask this in
a delicate way is Jimmer say okay he
didn't yeah he's okay I I knew you're
going to ask that and uh it's funny I
mentioned to somebody last night one of
my buddies is like is Jim okay and I
told him I have never seen him more
clear-eyed and clear-headed in my
20-something years that I've been in
Indianapolis than he is now I think he's
in a really good place
um but you said he was incoherent at the
President right but Jim but Jim that's
jim on a good day Dan I mean Jim even
when he's feeling well and he's thinking
clearly and he's sober minded that's
he's just a rambling guy you know
rambling man so uh that's just kind of
the way he operates but he is to my
knowledge in a good place where that
goes as an owner though I think he's
jumped the shark
yeah do you think Peyton Manning had a
say in this
well they call Peyton about everything
um I don't know because I I think Peyton
I I have not reached out to Peyton I
reached out but I I haven't gotten a
response response yet but
um
I I don't think Peyton was on board with
the Matt Ryan move you know
um no I don't think I I think this is
all Jim I'm sure I'm sure Jeff's
Saturday being the guy I'm sure that
Peyton was they checked in with Peyton
to see what he thought of that but all
the other stuff get rid of Reich
um I I don't know I I'm I'm kind of
guessing here and he also said it's a
great thing that he has no prior
coaching experience and also because he
doesn't have any fear I don't know if
anybody said to Jim irsay what was Frank
Reich in fear of was he was he fearful
of something if you're saying hey
Saturday makes sense he's not going to
be fearful was Frank Reich fearful
well the last couple of weeks he was
properly fearful he was afraid of going
forward on Fourth and short because his
offensive line stinks uh Jonathan Taylor
is hurt uh so he was not nearly as
aggressive as he's been in the past and
I can't say that I blame him
um I'll tell you what though he talked
about fear and analytics like yeah you
know we're not in the 21st century here
um if I'm the two analytics guys I'm
putting my resume out today
I'm like well apparently they don't need
us
it all goes back to Andrew Luck Bob
it does and he took a bullet you know he
took a bowl last night uh Earth say he
says well you know I've never had a
generational quarterback quit on me
before but look the the expiration date
the expiration date on that has passed
okay you know you you look at other team
you look at what what the New England
has done since they lost Brady you look
at what the Philadelphia Eagles have
done moving on to Jalen hurts in a new
coaching staff the the the expiration
date has passed that is no longer a
valid excuse they need to go out in the
draft get themselves somebody get a new
coach in here and move forward great to
talk to you Bob great talk to you Dan
take care give me the your odds that
this works out
is Jeff Saturday the head coach starting
next year
no
uh I would not say he's in the upper
quartile of the top quartile of guys
with a chance to
uh to to make it uh no he's gonna go one
and seven maybe Owen Eight two and six
it's not gonna be pretty I mean the
history of interim coaches is pretty
miserable and I you know a bad team is a
bad team is a bad team and uh you know I
I hope Jeff has some success but it's a
long shot for a guy who while Jim loves
his lack of experience
um was 20 and 16 in three years in high
school
good to check in with you as always Bob
all right thank you Bob Kravitz senior
staff writer for the athletic covering
the Colts